j'ai été déçu par ce débat parce que
j'attendais un débat intellectuel
d'idées et là où on flirtait sur le
débat par exemple de la guerre de
civilisation la crise de civilisation à
chaque fois les modérateurs était en
train de botter en touche il faut
avancer il faut avancer or je pense que
l'intérêt de ce débat entre un mélenchon
un zemmour c'est de rentrer dans le bien
fondé ou non d'une guerre de
civilisation est ce qu'elles existent
qu'est ce que c'est que la civilisation
occidentale voilà ce qu'est ce qu'il
existait ce que derrière on a un projet
de société et tout ça était balayée d'un
revers de main pour dit il faut parler
sécurité faut parler finalement comme si
vous étiez tous les deux candidats bien
sûr mais la fabrique zemmour n'a pas
besoin de sortir de son propos puisque
ce discours de civilisation en question
c'est ce qu'attendent les gens et ce
sont dont il parle on est d'accord avec
lui ou non et ce dont parle mélenchon
niveau de façon fait donc les mesures
tout le monde s'en fiche un peu emmanuel
macron encore une fois été élu non pas
sur des mesures mais sur ce qu'il était
sur ce qui l'a porté fasse qu'il était
censé apporter et ce qu'il incarne et je
pense que là les deux candidats ont
vraiment eu raison de rester chacun dans
leur corps même si c'est des soins en
fait pour le spectateur le premier qu'on
nous a vendu ça comme un combat de catch
s'était filmé avant par des duels on a
l'impression qu'ils allaient monter sur
le ring et s'est passé quelque chose
d'incroyable qui allait avoir une
ceinture wbc à la fin pour l'un ou pour
l'autre et en fait non comme vous le
dites ils ont été interrompues à chaque
jour leur a fait une petite liste de
courses alors dites nous ce que vous
dites là dessus et c'est je pense qu'on
est rentré dans une autre ère de
politique s'est dit politique spectacle
oui il faut s'en désole beaucoup très
désolant ce qu il peut ne pas y avoir
d'idée mais là en l'occurrence on avait
deux personnes qui étaient capables sont
des orateurs l'un et l'autre et être
capable d'exprimer justement comme vous
le dites et d'en dépenser dans le fond
et le spectacle aurait pu pour une fois
servir à quelque chose